walk back together with me Josh Smith
today we're joined by Princess Jasmine
but realized she's a queen it's never
Scott down and allowed himself muna
Masood how are you are you doing man
[Music]
agony with some Latin style life issues
okay okay are you ready I'm so inspired
by the film okay great okay so I met a
lad in the club
yeah okay and he's promising to show me
the world
yes he has a suspicious magic carpet
aka a pimp my ride s Golf GTI fringe so
cringe how do I know I can trust him or
should I even try or bother no what no
no you have to give him a shot okay you
have to make sure that he's gonna treat
you right okay okay you can never judge
someone by their car all their comfort
yes go on
however I would say that if you're
feeling the vibes and the
overcompensating right yeah agree with
Mina I'd say you know I'm a chance don't
give him the world maybe give him a
little patch of land all right like a
small patch of land thank you we're
going with the metaphors yes
we're loving the boat pose yeah no
softly what you mean okay Sean for harem
pants but I'm struggling to pull them
off and I'm looking more MC Hammer than
I'll add in right struggles okay what's
tiny parts would you get you've got to
slim down the legs but keep the thigh
and you know crotch area loose so you
still want a nice slim the leg so you
get the best of both worlds and make
sure your butt looks good oh it doesn't
need to be the whole way down but it
looks like you kind of know what you're
doing when it is
that's really good me not thank that's
great press without quite buggy on the
bottom yeah no no no there's gotta be
foggy bar or a sink the Kardashians
basically okay I've also got the dating
problems of really coming up thick and
fast okay I've just started dating a bad
boy a very the witching serpent okay too
far okay I know he's no good for me how
can I break the spell and leave him
oh no no I'm not I'm not I'm just saying
no but you know what I mean like cuz in
the movie right he does happen and he
smashes it yeah and just let it slip her
away yes just bye-bye bye-bye
let it cuz once you smash it it will go
of its own accord
yeah bully by was I exactly amazing well
I'm more empowered from that life advice
okay I loved it thanks so much
[Music]